GOOD MORNING -- WELCOME TO THE
RULES COMMITTEE FOR SOCIALLY
YEAH ROOM SERVICE CALL
TO ORDER THE ADVISE OF QUALITY
OF THE RECORDING OF TODAY'S
PROCEEDINGS BE MADE THIS ALSO BE
AMERICA SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL CLICK HERE CUNNINGHAM
CARILLO FLORA GRAYSON
HERE MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
QUIRK SILVA RAMOS SHARE
PREVIOUS WICKS WE HAVE A
WE HAVE A QUORUM WE HAVE THE
CONSENT AGENDA SO MOST OF
-- WILDERNESS COME ON BOTH
SIDES OF OUR MISSION OFFICE OF
MATTER SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL COOLEY AYE COOLEY AYE
CUNNINGHAM CARILLO CARILLO AYE
FLORA GRAYSON FIVE THREE I
KAMLAGER-DOVE BRIAN MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MATHIS MATHIS
AYE BURKE SILVA QUIRK SILVA
I RAMOS ALMOST AYE REAVIS
RIVERSIDE WORKS -- PROCESS
LOWER PRICES FOR SOME OF
THE STRONG FLORA THANK YOU
VERY GOOD -- THAT MOTION
PASSES AND THIS WAS WAS A
TRUCK THANK YOU VERY MUCH